legacy is greater than currency let's
get into that statement a little bit
more what am i favorite kind of I'm not
even sure if anybody's ever said it
before I'm sure somebody has but I'm all
about it I haven't heard it much but
I've been rocking it put on a t-shirt
what do I mean when I say legacy is
greater than currency you know I always
go from self inside of myself when I
communicate and talk to people and
that's why I think I'm able to
articulate it because it's it's my DNA
right and so everything I've ever done
when I first got into the liquor store
industry with my dad all I ever wanted
to do was be the biggest wine shop in
the world that was the number one agenda
and so what I talk about every business
decision that I ever made every one of
them was always based on my long-term
legacy as being the biggest wine
retailer in the world I like trying to
point at that thing anyway and so that
was the key that was my entire thought
process so when I was paying myself
nothing even though the business was
exploding and when I was letting other
managers take vacations in lieu of my
vacation time all these decisions every
one of them you can't skip every one of
them has to be about your long-term
legacy it can't be about the dollars
you're putting in your pocket or more
importantly taking a Series A or some VC
money what is it gonna do are they gonna
let take make you take you make you vest
in five years or you gonna have to wait
five years to cash out a lot of people
do that because it's this money they're
not monetizing right now they're not
making the cash right so you take in
this extra flow they take percentages
you're on the board what have you but
wait a minute
you're now in theory really locked into
this game for five years and in this
world and I'm doing this because I'm
trying to show you in this world where
things are changing every minute where
players are changing every minute if
you're a hustler if you're a very hard
worker and you're putting everything on
the line put it into your own personal
brand just make rent pay your bills and
keep building your personal brand and
always think of a big picture the legacy
who are you going to be viewed at when
it's all said and done you know so many
people are like my children my legacy
absolutely but where is your personal
brand and your business whatever you're
involved in where is that's legacy
where's that legacy where is that legacy
I'm gonna say it again
where is that legacy and the reason I
keep pounding it is because of this I
truthfully believe all the way that if
every business decision you make from
hiring a secretary to buy what paint
you buy whether it's like earth-friendly
right to every move you make if the
first question you ask is how does this
affect my legacy my long-term legacy
when it's all said and done I guarantee
the currency will be there at the end
I'd much rather have a million friends
right now than a million dollars not
even more than a hundred million dollars
the world is changing we're more
connected and your legacy you're
maneuvering your decision-making process
has to start at your long-term legacy
big picture always wins and so if you
take every decision out there that you
can make from who you're gonna be
surrounded by who are your friends right
people are looking for short-term
traffic right you know Digg StumbleUpon
this and that silly things like that or
who your circle friends are or any of
those kinds of decisions minor decisions
what conferences you go to what what
color is your website everything
everything has to start with how is this
going to impact my global legacy and I
guarantee you when you make legacy
decisions instead of quick cash
decisions or mid-range cast of cash
decisions you're gonna win every time
when you come from that thought process
when you add it to the DNA game that we
talked about being your DNA when you add
it to not lying to yourself when you
break down these and you start putting
these pieces in place you start winning
I'll give you some good examples because
I'm gonna really give you details
I was buying full-page New York Times
ads that were costing me $30,000 when I
was paying myself $28,000 a year in
business why because I was investing in
my legacy I wasn't worried about getting
a new car when I was 24 or like with all
my other friends even though I know I
was building something bigger and that's
what you need to do you need to survive
and thrive you need to just keep it
going you know you gotta pay your bills
so your family do all those things right
stay healthy have a little excess cash
just so you can buy a Wii or something
to make you happy but at all times all
times I on the price legacy is greater
than currency your social gosh your
social equity is far greater than your
financial equity it's not even close and
all these technologies are only making
that more obvious please if anything
after this video what is your legacy is
going to be the question you need to ask
yourself before you make any kind of
financial decision legacy my friends
is greater than currency